NOW, WHAT IS IT?
BRIT HUME AND JONATHAN TURLEY
WILL JOIN US TO SPELL THAT OUT.
MARK ZUCKERBERG SPENT HOURS ON
CAPITOL HILL TODAY TAKING
QUESTIONS FROM SENATORS ABOUT
FACEBOOK'S ROLE IN THE 2016
ELECTION IN AN AMERICAN SOCIETY
MORE GENERALLY.
WILL TALK TO ONE OF THE SENATORS
WAS THERE AND SPOKE TO
ZUCKERBERG AND WHAT IT MEANT.
BUT FIRST, BRAD LARSEN WHO
COVERS TECH FOR OUR SHOW HAS BIG
MOMENTS FROM TODAY.
>> FACEBOOK CEO MARK ZUCKERBERG
CHECKED IN WITH CONGRESS TODAY
FOR DAY ONE OF HEARINGS.
WE LEARNED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THE INNER WORKINGS OF THE SOCIAL
MEDIA GIANT.
ONE THING WE HEARD REPEATEDLY
WAS EXACTLY WHAT FACEBOOK IS AND
IS NOT.